now easyjet has blamed recent disruption
at airports after it reported a pre-tax
loss of 114 million pounds for the three
months to the end of june well that was
despite the airline carrying seven times
as many passengers as in the same period
last year the loss was down from one of
318 million pounds in the same period a
year ago easyjet said the disruption
chipped 133 million pounds from its
earnings well joining me now is the
chief executive of easyjet johan
lundgren johann welcome to you after
turkish airlines you've had the worst
cancellation rates this summer why is
that
no not if you're looking at an overall
picture across the whole of the european
aviation you would have seen from
instance that from the start of the june
uh until you know middle of july as well
we actually be one of the better ones
when it comes to the cancellations in
there so it depends on what better point
in time you're looking what is true
though uh is that we did have some you
know challenges particularly around that
first weekend of april and um
under the queen's jubilee week as well
but the actions and the messages were
taken is definitely working and now
we're running a stabler program very
much in line with 2019. i can just just
to finish that to give you an example
over the weekend we flew over 3100
flights here we didn't have a senior
cancellation in the in the uk and over
39 000 flies from the start of july with
normal levels of of operation
can you promise that there will be no
more cancellations this summer have you
got capacity where you need it to be now
well you know we are confident on the
actions that we have taken and they are
apparently working but you know clearly
you know we can't help if there's a
a patch at a runway that melts because
of the heat which means that the airport
doesn't allow departures arrivals take
place those types of events however rare
they are they will have a consequence
and equally when there are shortages for
instance around the air traffic control
that causes delays that could lead to
impact also clearly on our customers and
of course in the worst case also
cancellations but i think from the
actions that we have taken we are now
seeing that that is working and we
gather a program that is now stabilized
very much in line with the 2019 levels
of operation
what do you say to those people who
accuse you of having laid off too many
people during the pandemic and
that you're now struggling to recruit
but first of all it wasn't really an
option was it i mean we we had the
toughest restrictions in in across the
whole of the europe but we didn't know
when this restriction was going to be
lifted remember that the last
restrictions were lifted here in the uk
only as late as as in march and even by
the early part of of the this calendar
year you know the the government
couldn't say anything about the the
removal of these restrictions being in
place
so that wasn't simply an option but we
have recruited more people than we ever
done before in order to make sure that
we can deliver the summer and you know
we did have challenges and for that you
know we deeply regret that if that has
affected casper and it has to some
extent but i must also then say that you
know since the actions we have taken
here seems to pretty much you know
throughout the the queen's jubilee week
and onwards we have delivered a stable
program we're flying
you know some 250 000 customers per day
with the the same performance you would
expect to see in in a normal year
what about industrial relations you've
got a few strikes going on around the
business uh in in coming weeks do you
have a problem on that front
well i think to the extent that we have
had those issues as well i think we've
been you know very good in mitigating
that in terms of planning around that
and we continue to work you know
constructively with our union partners
in order to make sure that we can get
resolutions on these things and this is
something that is not you know clearly
unique for one airline that exists
freely across the whole of the ecosystem
as well and for that matter not only
within this industry so that's something
that we're going to continue to work
focus on together with our partners
now during the pandemic you stopped
flying out of newcastle south end and
stansted i noticed that you're you're
back to an extent at some of those sites
now was it a mistake to pull out from
those
no i think that that is something that
that that we did because we had to
restructure the network and what we did
was also down to to remove unprofitable
flying that we had and we weren't happy
with that performance because at the
same time we also saw that we had bigger
demand elsewhere that we wanted to
fulfill as part of that so that is part
of kind of the ongoing way on how we
optimize
the network to really meet the customer
demand that we have across the
whole of our operations
now you're the biggest carrier operating
at gatwick how unhelpful is it that
they've capped passenger numbers in the
way they have
well i i i think that i might be a
little bit different to some of the
other airline ceos of this i think that
you know it is better to have an airport
who are assessing the capacity levels
and the resilience level across the
whole of the the network the ground
handlers and the security staff and what
they actually think that they are
capable of delivering and if they feel
that they can't do that and they obsess
that that is the case it's better to
give a heads up on that so we can plan
our programs accordingly i mean it's not
great and disappointing to the effect
that that has for the customers but you
rather do that don't you rather than to
have customers coming out to the airport
and then suddenly realize that the
flight discounts is on the day because
that is the worst thing that that that
you really want to avoid so you know we
we've been supportive of what gatwick
has been doing in terms of those
capacity costs because if they just
don't think that they can operate it we
shouldn't risk the customers being
stranded there on on the day
now obviously you're seeing a lot of
pent-up demand in the business right now
i just wonder how how it is specifically
in business travel obviously leisure is
pretty buoyant what about business
travel
we definitely see that that is is coming
back as well we do see that those routes
that we have you know you know a high
proportion of business travel is being
being in place i think we're now down to
you know what would be a normal a lower
level of period as well because it's
it's in the middle of the summer so that
business travel hasn't you know come
back to to to to those levels that would
seem but that follows a kind of a normal
pattern in there but i think in general
the trends on what people are booking
and not booking you can say that we're
strong into the mediterranean and that
does really well we've seen some
softness into the domestic flying in
certain cases uh we we do see that for
instance from a holiday the people tend
to gravitate towards the all-inclusive
uh proposition because it probably gives
you know people then you know the
security of what the cost is going to be
on on that holiday
but it's really the traditional beach
and leicester routes that is doing well
for us
all right good to talk to you this
morning thanks for joining me
thank you